weapons of fallen warriors his face
scarred
with one dead eye disney's brave
is full of loud rambunctious characters
it's set in the scottish highlands after
all but it's merida's three little
brothers who steal the show without ever
saying a word
harris hubert and hamish are identical
triplets who love to cause mischief
especially when there are sweets
involved while they can be a handful the
triplets are so much more than comic
relief
their pranking ways are not only
hysterically funny but end up being
crucial in helping merida get out of
trouble
you won't believe what kind of antics
these wee devils get up to
your father has something to discuss
with you
here's a question how do you sneak an
eight-foot tall grizzly bear out of a
castle without anyone noticing
with the help of three mischievous
pranksters of course when merida's
mother gets unwittingly transformed into
a bear
[Music]
she turns to her three little brothers
for help in sneaking out of the castle
in the end merida trades a whole year of
her dessert in exchange for the triplets
help
using nothing but a chicken a stick and
a clay pot
the triplets cast a shadow to create the
illusion of a bear
then they lure the king in his lords
away so that merida can finally escape
with her mother
but the icing on the cake the boys draw
the king's mob to the very top of the
tower
and lock them outside worth giving up a
year's worth of dessert
we think so in fact we are pretty sure
that without the triplets in their bag
of tricks
merida would have never made it out of
the castle at all even after the
brothers locked the king and other lords
at the top of the tower
it's locked ding war was the last stop
they still have to get past moddy the
nurse maid
who's already freaking out from seeing a
bear in the castle
once again though the triplets come
through with an outrageous prank that
helps clear the way for merida's escape
one of the triplets puts the chicken on
his head and jumps down the chimney
to give modi the fright of her life we
can't help but laugh as she runs away
screaming
who knew chickens could be scarier than
bears don't be fooled though
while they will help their sister out in
a pinch harris hubert and hamish are
more likely to be the ones
causing trouble than fixing it most of
the time they simply enjoy causing chaos
we can't complain though because the
result sure is fun to watch
the best example is probably when the
other clans arrived to dunbroch to
compete for merida's hand in marriage
the presentation of the presentation of
the shootout
at the presentation all of the lords
start squabbling and get into a huge
fight
but don't worry king fergus is there to
calm everyone down
that is until his sons decide to do
something about it they sneak up through
a trap door
and hit lord dingwall on the foot to
send everyone brawling again
mayhem ensues and the triplets get to
sit back and enjoy the show
it's clear from the very first moment
that we meet the triplets
just how clever and conniving they are
and just how far they'll go for a tasty
dessert
the boys have a seemingly endless
appetite so of course they're always
cooking up schemes to steal pastries
from their nurse-made modi
when we first see them the boys are
sneaking around and stealing tarts from
right under moddy's nose
we devils is right the triplets managed
to steal a whole plate of tarts before
moddy even knows what hit her
they escape with the goods by jumping
out of the window for an incredible
getaway by catapult
devils more like daredevils
with that kind of energy it's no wonder
they're always hungry
but if you thought that was the last of
marty's trouble with the triplets
think again moddy really can't catch a
break when it comes to these three
later in the movie the highland games
are getting underway and it's a perfect
opportunity for more pranking
this time though they sneak down over a
tent and steal tarts from above
the boys distract moddy and take her
pastries while she's not looking
modi tries her best to deflect them and
salvage the desserts but she's no match
for harris
hubert and hamish she thinks she has
them when she traps them inside of a
barrel
but no she's actually played right into
their scheme
and they simply take the barrel and all
the tarts with them
moddy chases after them struggling to
keep up as they
barrel through crowds of people in the
end the boy's penchant for sweet treats
gets them more than
anyone could have bargained for the
triplets eat what's left of the
enchanted cake
and are transformed into identical bear
cubs cute right
well apparently not for everyone after
merida is locked away in the tapestry
room
moddy holds the key to her escape and
her brothers just so happen to be there
to
help in their bear cub state it doesn't
take much to send moddy fleeing in
terror
yet again they chase her throughout the
castle and finally corner her in an
empty room
one of the cubs makes a jump for moddy's
shirt where she's hidden the key
smash cut and next thing we know the
boys have the key in paw
we can only imagine what went down even
as bear cubs the triplets never seem to
lose their mischievous spirit
which is just the thing to get merida
out of trouble
and like most young boys the triplets
can't help but play with their food
we don't really blame them for not
wanting to eat haggis though
yuck but merida it seems knows her
brothers all too well when they refuse
to eat their haggis she offers them a
gift instead
you guessed it a plate of delicious
tarts stolen from the kitchen no less
clearly the boys have rubbed off on
merida or maybe they
learned it from her she is their big
sister after all
either way they slip under the table one
by one to snack away
when the boys are finally dismissed from
the room they run away with pastries
stuffed into their shirts
hilariously falling all over each other
but that's not all
while they were hiding the triplets tied
king fergus's leg to the table without
anyone noticing
i think you can see where this is
heading the payoff comes when merida
storms off and the queen looks to her
husband to go after
and console her he gets up to leave and
that's when the whole table comes
crashing down
thanks to the boys handiwork
this moment is a great way to cut the
tension of the serious moment that came
before it
the king bringing down the table and all
the food with it is the perfect
unexpected prank to make us laugh after
the heaviness of merida's disagreement
with her mother
even when they're not in the room the
triplets still manage to make a huge
impact
now that's how you steal a scene next up
there's a blink and you'll almost miss
it moment but it shows how funny the
brothers are
even when they're just in the background
it's dinner time
and king fergus is sharing the tale of
how he lost his leg to the monstrous
bear mordu
oh that's my favorite part
has never been seen since
and he's obviously quite the storyteller
but it might be time for him to find
some new stories to tell
you'll notice that while hubert and
hamish or is that harris
are bored out of their wits the
remaining triplet is having a blast by
mimicking the king's
every word in action they've clearly
heard this story many many times before
with these three around dinner time
would never be boring
they also find other ways to make their
own fun around the castle
we'd probably resort to pranking too if
we didn't have movies like this one to
pass the time with
but one poor guard falls asleep on the
job and gets pranked by the triplets for
his trouble
the brothers use an axe to snip off half
his mustache
and they're gone just as quickly as they
appeared we definitely wouldn't want to
be caught sleeping with these three
around
finally near the end of the movie once
all is said and done
it's time for the other clans to say
goodbye and sail home
but not before a certain trio of
tricksters is able to stow away on one
of the ships
first the triplets can be seen tearing
through the docks using shields like
skateboards
then as the people of dunbroch wave
goodbye to the visiting lords
king fergus is shocked to see his sons
waving back to him from the top of the
mast
so much for smooth sailing how the boys
managed to get up there is beyond us
but we couldn't help but laugh as the
king begrudgingly goes after them
on a rowboat brave clearly wouldn't be
the same without the highland hijinks
these three get up to
which of these hilarious pranks did you
enjoy the most let us know in the
comments below
and don't forget to hit that subscribe
button for more videos on all things
disney
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
you